hey Walter I feel really bad about that
powering missing a couple of days ago
and I just wanted Walter
Walter Walter Walter
that's weird he's normally here by three
what love worry about rules and they got
money I feel I still vivid in 11i behind
your back
[Music]
oh no Walter oh no I'm Heather Ruth and
these are the top five worst
performances of Walter Ben vennett than
you know what I'm talking about number
five the Ghostbusters priest in the
soldier critics review for Ghostbusters
2016 I know I was in that review but
what exactly what Walter even doing
you must pop see my risk unimaginably
far only moon or something dude I guess
he's trying to be a southern minister or
something
sounds more like Dusty Rhodes without
the list so let's just fuck you like a
monkey I'm one thing to say Walter shame
shame sure number four
Jason loan Sabine and I'm still here no
not that one yeah bad one so from what I
can gather Walter and his friends made
this in early college it's a feature
film their second apparently and Walter
looks like a strung-out 80s rocker I
mean look at that what is on his head is
it alive does it breathe Walter's acting
here yeah you go on Lenny hide behind
your badge and your doorstep turn
arrived at an innocent woman murdered in
an alleyway I won't I'm still here
[Laughter]
number three Sean Branson in you are
this was the first movie Walter made he
was in high school we all go through
weird phases but seeing Walter try to be
a badass that's priceless
remember what I do have a little gift
for you think of it think of it as a
vacation vacation
oh yeah I'm really scared
what are you gonna do warm to death with
your introspective narration cold
desolate heart I often find myself
questioning whether that's the
description of this gunned down city or
of my own heart our man of the streets
I'm out of the dark I made of the night
I'll never look at Fedora's the same way
again number two number two Shawn
Michaels in superkick safety for the
record
Walter was trying to imitate this guy
Hogan at SummerSlam but sounded like
this this superkick must be used only
when completely absolutely positively
necessary please remember that the Sweet
Chin Music otherwise known as a
superkick okay I'm going to use in the
most extreme situations never use it
except for self-defense
like when being attacked by bed high
school project and the number one worst
wolterman easyacc performance is it Zack
Snyder oh come on he sounds nothing like
him yeah so put these two old movies
idea on the shelf in the background for
this week just a leisure a watching no
they're pretty embarrassed
what are you doing here ever April Fool
Oh
[Music]
you